good afternoon my name is Amy mccre I'm
the coordinator of the technology and
culture Forum at MIT and it's my great
pleasure to welcome you to this event
new roles for established media this is
the second of a two-part conversation
that may turn into a three-part
conversation on democracy and the media
and how the role of the media may or may
not be changing and having an impact on
our political system as we uh approach
next week's
election uh as I said this is the second
of what we have is a two-part series and
our hope is to do a sort of postmortem
event uh next February to look back on
the election and take a look at what
happened and the role that the media did
play so please uh uh stay posted for
that watch for that this series is being
brought to you as a joint project of the
technology and culture forum and the MIT
Communications forum and I want to thank
David thorburn and the people at the
communications Forum it's been a real
pleasure to work with you on this really
um important
series we're very glad to have with us
this evening three excellent panelists
to lead this conversation and a great
moderator to help keep us on track and
uh in a moment I'll introduce to you
that moderator and get started I do want
to let you know though as we begin that
uh Amy Mitchell one of our presenters
this evening uh has uh provided us with
a handout and some of you may have
picked that up on your way in uh it's a
a summary of a report that her group has
just published this week if you didn't
get a copy of it you can also download
it from the website of the
communications Forum uh which looks like
this if you go to the MIT communic Forum
website and click right
here you will go to the page about
today's event and then at the bottom of
the page uh you can click here on the
title of the report and get a copy of it
for yourself so if you didn't get a hard
copy today that's how you can get a copy
after the
event our format this evening will be
that each of the speakers will speak for
uh for about 15 minutes or so 15 or 20
minutes and then we'll have uh plenty of
time for questions from you afterwards
uh we'll we're scheduled to go until 7
p.m and so we should have at least an
hour for
conversation um if you have a question
please do come down to either the
microphone on this aisle or the
microphone here on this aisle so that we
can record your voice and your excellent
wise question um and so that all of us
can hear your excellent wise
question and with that let me introduce
the moderator of this evening's
conversation Steven Van everra is a
professor of political science here at
MIT and his uh specialty is
international relations and US foreign
policy he teaches classes here at MIT on
the causes and prevention of war and on
uh National Security and international
relations and we're really glad that
he's agreed to shepher this conversation
this evening so thank you
Steve
[Applause]
thanks Amy I just want to introduce all
three of our panelists and uh uh and
remind you how to um do your Q&A uh when
we get to Q&A all I want to remind you
there is that we're uh recording this
for MIT World which is the spot on the
website where you can go to see uh past
events at MIT where they're uh where you
can find them on streaming video and so
if you when we get to Q&A time uh use
the mics so that uh MIT world will catch
your questions um tonight we got three
panelists they're all terrific and
thanks so much for coming over to MIT in
the order in which they're going to
speak first is going to be Amy Mitchell
she's the associate director of the
project for excellence in journalism in
Washington DC uh where she oversees uh
research and empirical studies that come
out of that project she's also the
editor of a book that came out in 2003
called thinking clearly cases in
journalistic decisionmaking um and she's
going to speak first then we're going to
have um Alex Jones who's a very
distinguished uh journalist worked for
nine years at the New York Times uh
covering uh the Press from 1983 to '92
he won a Pitzer prize there uh in 1987
uh uh he's been a Neeman fellow at
Harvard and you've often heard him on
NPR where he's the uh host of NPR's uh
uh show on the media and he's also host
and director executive director of the
PBS TV show Media Matters um and so so
we're very glad he's here here tonight
and uh lastly Mark jerkovich who's the
media writer for um I should point to
who's who can you read their names Mark
trovich Alex Jones Amy Mitchell um
lastly Mark trovich who is Media writer
for the Boston Globe um he's been doing
that since 1987 he earlier was meteor
critic for the uh Phoenix Boston Phoenix
and you've often seen him on uh uh
Channel 2 uh on the uh beat the press
program which is once a week week right
with Emily Rooney right there you go so
you at s at 7 o'clock you can either
choose to listen to Tom Ashbrook or Mark
jerkovich have to
watch is that true yeah ah okay great
okay so there's uh more options coming
our way so Amy uh you're first and I I
suggested maybe 20 minutes uh for each
and uh then we'll have a lot of time for
Q&A Amy
Mitchell
thank you it's a pleasure to be here
this evening even though I am a St Louis
native and a big baseball fan so uh
congratulations I
guess the question of today's Forum uh
are New Media transforming today's news
that we're receiving and the electoral
system clearly the role of the press in
our society is a crucial one since our
country's birth the role of Journalism
has been defined often as providing
citizens with information so that they
can govern themselves the election is
perhaps the Pinnacle of citizens
decision-making power and new forms of
media and the new 24-hour news influence
the Press practices and Reporting about
the election as well as the quality and
the type of information that we get so
what kinds of Trends have these media
set how have they helped in the
political process they certainly have
offered some good
internet links to voter guides and
background information about the
candidates are clearly an asset as are
more availability of verbatim candidate
speeches blogs are an opportunity to
hear from those outside the mainstream
press and to offer our own voices in
response even cable can help by getting
information to Citizens quickly what we
have now is more of an OnDemand news
consumer getting news even Mark's uh
news uh election or other when and in
what form we want and this can be an
asset but these Innovations must
necessarily come after the most
fundamental role of the press that is
reporting providing the
information here the New Media don't
seem to be raising the caliber very much
in fact what we've recently seen from
the newest Forum blogs is mostly a
furthering of Tendencies established in
cable and the mainstream
press uh as uh the the introductory
remarks mentioned there are copies of of
a study that we just released yesterday
that looks at coverage during the debate
period uh that is the first two weeks of
October the study the main part of the
study looked at newspapers Network
evening and Morning News and and two
cable shows it finds an amplification of
the tendencies that emerged in the 2000
campaign a strong perance towards
reporting about inside politics 55% of
stories focused on political internals
like the candidates performance or the
campaign tactics the latest strategies
this was a 14o increase over
2000 in coverage specifically about the
debate political internals jumped to 79%
of all the
coverage policy discussions in contrast
were largely absent just 133% of the
coverage focused on explaining policy
almost exactly the same as in
2000 and again in debate coverage the
picture got worse just 4% of the
coverage so in these four debates when
citizens are supposed to be learning the
differences and where each of the
candidates would take the country over
the next four years less than one in 20
stories actually examined
policies in addition to the frames of
stories we looked at something else who
did these stories predominantly impact
based on how the stories were put
together who is most affected by the
events described is it citizens
politicians interest groups about 34s of
the coverage we studied was written in a
way that mostly impacted politicians
just 20% primarily impacted
citizens this concept of impact can be a
little bit hard to grasp so I'll just
take a second to try to explain it if
you think about it any topic um whatever
you're writing about can be developed in
een different ways think about a story
about a car crash on First and Main
Street it could be written as a way of
discussing the teenager that was driving
and the rise in teenage car fatalities
it could lead to a discussion about the
intersection as one that many citizens
have complained of being dangerous or
perhaps discuss the fact that it took
the police an hour to get there a sure
sign of the governor's recent budget
cuts one example in this study is a
print story on the eve of the second
debate that was devoted to outlining how
different events in the news had added
quote unquote new ammunition for the
carry campaign in this upcoming
debate so again we saw 74% mostly
impacting politicians versus just 20%
that mostly impacted citizens compared
with 200 this is a 7% decline in citizen
impact and an increase in the politician
impact so we have politics over policy
politicians over
citizens then we ask how do the media
differ are the newer media altering
these Tendencies changing the nature of
reporting are they getting better the
short answer in this study seems to be
no television was more prone than
newspapers to frames of inside baseball
they were more likely to produce stories
that impacted politicians over citizens
in cable we looked at just two programs
CNN's news night with Aaron Brown and
Fox's news program with Brit Hume but we
saw many of the same
Tendencies so we then did a separate
examination of the newest media
phenomena the blogs we looked at five of
the most popular blogs to see if their
focus over these two weeks differed from
that of the main mream press overall we
found them to be conspicuously similar
to the mainstream press in what they
covered the tone of that coverage and
even in the angle that the writers
took the vast majority of debate
postings were focused on inside politics
fully
70% these are mostly evaluations of the
candidate's performance often in real
time you know throughout the campaign
you get these continuous postings of of
the latest comment that one of the
candidates made a mere 6% of all the
debate related postings focused on
policies of one candidate or
another these findings seem to suggest
that the blogosphere may not be changing
the media agenda as much as adding more
pointed personal and frankly blunt
voices excuse me in other words
furthering the growth of opinion news
but in an even more one-sided way than
the cable talk
shows so that brings us back around to
the most basic question
excuse me of how much a citizen is aided
by increased amounts of information and
more convenient access if the
information itself is less useful or at
least less geared towards the needs of
citizens I'll now just take a minute to
address another question that was raised
in the um in the forum's overview which
is the question about Fox news's highest
ratings during the Republican
convention and it's seems to me that the
bigger question is the choice of the
networks not covering it choosing not to
cover the bulk of the conventions and
what this signified was that the
prestige in many ways and the influence
of the news divisions at these networks
are no longer
important so if the networks end up
seeding TV news to cable what difference
might that make for one different ways
of giving the news um in cable and in
network will provide a different outcome
Network news is primarily built around
packages the carefully written edited
produced packages in a 2003 study that
we did 84% of network news came out as
packages cable on the other hand is a
live extemporaneous medium just 11% of
their coverage was edited in what we
studied in
2003 what's lost in this live coverage
in this live medium is the time to
double check to verify the time to
report
and I think what we'll see is even more
of that if you look at what's coming out
in the
blogosphere so a fox's convention
audience may not be all about Fox it
certainly does seem to be
significant thanks I look forward to the
other
[Applause]
comments uh thanks Amy I guess this is
working next uh Alex
hello glad to be with you as
well
um you have now heard I'm sure so many
times that uh it's boring that this is a
an election of enormous perhaps
Transcendent importance in terms of our
own lives anyway I would argue that the
the election this election is also of an
extreme important nature to the media in
this country not in as clear cutaway um
as the bush carry demarcation we know
that after election night next week
sooner or later after election night
next week we will be on one path or the
other it will be quite clear uh with the
media um I think that the election
mostly has given us a moment to look at
what has happened since even 2000 and
where we are going you heard the uh
excellent uh analysis content analysis
uh that Amy gave you what I'm going to
give you is more impressionistic perhaps
but I think that it captures for me
anyway some of the themes that I see
emerging um that are uh very uh they're
genuinely troubling I think they are
ones that are uh fundamentally
recognizable to you I suspect but it may
not be that you have H put these in
quite this context um we'll
see let me begin with with the question
of how good a job have the media done
this is a perennial question about this
time uh for elections and it really is
the question that really is being asked
is how poor a job is the media done I
mean there's always the the presumption
of failure and it's fair because the the
fact is that we look at at uh these kind
of job reviews and they are inevitably
filled with things left undone and and
Roads taken that perhaps should not have
been and as Amy described emphasis that
was misplaced but I'd like to come at it
from a somewhat different perspective
and asked and ask the the the question
do the people in this country know
enough to make up their minds about who
to vote for which is really the point of
campaign coverage it seems to me for
this we need to begin with a concept
that you may have heard of called
rational ignorance rational ignorance is
the mechanism that we all employ to do
some screening we decide if an issue is
something we need to know more about and
therefore need to take the time to learn
more about or if it is something that we
satisfy ourselves that we know enough
about to make up our minds and the
likelihood that we can't do anything
about something increases greatly the
likelihood that we would not take the
time to learn in great detail about you
know the the plight of Ecuador right now
or even something that's much more
timely is is what's going on in Sudan
the idea of of rational ignorance simply
says that we use our time in our
attention which is limited uh to the in
the way that we spend our money we spend
it in the way that we consider to be
wisest um and so we here now in this
election are presented with a highly
highly politicized uh body of Voters uh
predictions are that this will be a an
election that will have a higher vote
than any vote since 1960 and may exceed
1960 um the the vote is being made by
people who for the most part have made
up their minds already and have already
said they've made up their minds in most
cases even weeks ago there are still
some people there obviously are things
changing all the time we see the
variations in uh in polling uh I I was
told today that in the state of Iowa
virtually every person who is eligible
to vote is now registered I mean Almost
100% registration in Iowa I think what
that says is that there is a a body of
people out there who have satisfied
themselves for whatever reasons and on
whatever basis that they know enough to
make up their minds about who should be
president
then you take that to the next level and
you try to Plum what they know and
whether they know enough by any kind of
objective standard to feel that way uh
the most amazing set of Statistics that
I've yet seen in this election were
released About a Week Ago by the program
on International policy attitudes at the
University of
Maryland this organization tracks what
people what voters prospective voters
say they say who they're going to vote
for who they're inclined to vote for and
what they believe to be that
person's uh you know platform what he
stands for what he's for and what he's
against and what they found was that
while the people who say they're going
to vote for Carrie have a reasonably
good uh idea of what Carrie is for and
what he's against what he stands for in
his campaign and what he is not what he
is against in his campaign the uh the
people who say they are going to vote
for George Bush not all of them but
significant numbers of them have some
astonishing ideas about what George
Bush's policies are for instance over
half of them believe all the over half
of the people who say they are probably
going to vote for George Bush believe
that George Bush supports the Kyoto
treaties they believe that he is uh for
the environmental treaties that uh he is
very much against 70% of them according
to these this data believe that he
supports the comprehens testband
treaty even more remarkably to me
70% of those who say they're going to
vote for Bush believe that bush had the
support of world public opinion when he
invaded Iraq and 90% well let me put it
this way only 10% of those who are say
they're going to vote for George
Bush seem to understand and say they
understand that if a vote were Tak taken
throughout the world George Bush would
lose that they understand that he is not
the popular choice of the rest of the
world which leaves 90% of George Bush
supporters and prospective voters who
apparently believe that if it was if it
was a question they would say no the
world supports George Bush uh for this
election now the reason I mentioned this
is not to sort of mock George Bush
supporters I don't that's not my meaning
I don't I don't think that that's a fair
thing I think they have made up their
minds about George Bush on other issues
issues they do know enough about to feel
comfortable with but the point is that
the media effort in this regard has
informed the carry people but has not
apparently informed the bush people at
least in areas that seem obvious to
those of us and I would imagine that
includes virtually everybody in this
room that has who have followed this
election carefully does that mean that
the media has failed or that there is
really something hopeless about the
process of thinking that putting things
in the newspaper and on television in a
factual sense are going to alter the
fundamental point which is who are you
for and who are you against the the the
power that this seems to me to suggest
is that the vote does not depend on
having the right understanding of an
issue it shows that for many people that
this is an emotional issue and that what
they gather from the media is not
necessarily the facts but Impressions
which brings us to what they're seeing
on television and what they're reading
on the web and what they're reading in
newspapers if you go back to the
campaign of 2000 it seems to me that the
it was almost uh it was almost like a
campaign of of of of antique nature I
mean the New York Times And The
Washington Post and the major newspapers
had a very very powerful role in
defining what became the meta Narrative
of The Campaign which was widely
criticized but nevertheless the
fundamental power to Define George Bush
as dumb and Al Gore as a as a liar
stemmed largely from the reporting that
was done by the mainstream media and
then was picked up and Amplified by
cable news it the flow went from Mostly
newspapers which put the resources in to
do the reporting television has
historically picked that up and used
that and that has sort of migrated in
the time of cable news to uh to cable
news now that's all been stood on its
head in this in the four years since uh
that election uh blogging existed of
course in the year 2000 but nothing
compared to what it is now really
nothing uh the the uh the the idea that
Matt drudge when he outed Bill Clinton
as far as Monica Lewinsky was concern uh
is a reflection of what's going on today
I think is completely wrong uh what's
happened that is important in the four
years since 2000 is that blogging
especially blogging of a political
nature blogging uh focused on politics
and public policy has grown into this uh
incredibly rapidly expand ing network of
people who are willing to give an
enormous amount of energy and attention
to it often are highly informed or and
are very opinionated and most important
are being read are being read not
necessarily by most people in this
country but by journalists and
especially by the people who decide what
is news for cable television cable
television has 24 hours to fill up it's
a very competitive environment they are
trying to make it as much money as they
can which means they're going to spend
as little as they can on doing real
reporting they're looking for the story
of the day or maybe two of the day and
so for that reason when a great story
emerges and often it is now emerging
from the blogosphere it can go straight
from the blogosphere to the cable news
channel that's what happened essentially
with the Swift boo story The Swift booat
story was a story that had standing
because the people who were saying it
were not crazy people I mean the thing
is they were people who had standing
they were former naval officers so they
had an inherent believability but the
story had never been checked that was a
standard that did not apply not apply to
table news it applied to the New York
Times or the Washington Post or ABC but
it did not apply to the blog and it did
not apply to cable news and so it was on
the air on cable news being beaten to
death not necessarily
on the basis of it being true but of on
the basis of it being talked about and
by people sort of saying it and maybe
somebody was saying it was not true but
there was no Arbiter of truth that
emerged until about 10 days after it
appeared when the New York Times And The
Washington Post finally publish stories
that take time to do and what has
happened in the course of this 2004
election that's one of the most
important things I believe is that the
news organizations that still have the
resources and will to report
are being totally manipulated by the
blog and cable news it's been turned
around now the Washington Post and the
New York Times spent an enormous amount
of their energy factchecking
factchecking and I think that that's
something that is going to only increase
I think that when you have on the blog
the blogosphere the vehicle for
factchecking mainstream journalists that
can work very well I mean the CBS Dan
Rather phony uh documents story I think
that was a blogger Triumph because it
was one of those moments when people who
sat out there who had expertise looked
that it saw something wrong and
instantly it was out there and and the
mainstream media are being faced on the
best side with that kind of factchecking
but what has happened is also that the
news cycle and how news is how
information gets turned into front page
highly impressionistic news has changed
its direction from the mainstream to
cable news to a bubbling up in many
cases not always of course but bubbling
up in many cases from the blogosphere
and making it directly to cable news
which then migrates its way into the
mainstream news businesses now as that's
happening the question is what's
happening with the news business I mean
the thing is this is the journalistic
side of it but a lot of it's being
driven by something I'm not going to
talk in detail about tonight but it's
something that you need to fundamentally
understand understand which is that
what's happening now in the in the new
technological age is that the audience
has gone from being a mass audience to a
tiny fragmented audience that means that
in order to make money you have a
Cutthroat competitive environment
everybody is desperately trying to
attract and to attract an audience the
vehicle you fundamentally use in this
country is to invest your you know
whatever you have with as much
entertainment Pizazz as much snap
crackle and pop as much violence
argument whatnot uh as you can and you
spend as little as you can also on
reporting which is why it's only the
major newspapers in this country that
now devote the
resources to uh to reporting and their
reporting is now increasingly I think
going to be spent on factchecking stuff
that is already in
circulation so let me talk very briefly
about Sinclair broadcasting because
that's also a very big Point part of the
business side of this and and also the
journalistic part I'm sure that some of
you probably were unhappy about what
happened with St Clair I was overjoyed I
was thrilled that Sinclair did something
so bald and palpably abusive of the fact
that they had been able in this
Administration to benefit from changes
in FCC regulations that allowed them to
put together 60 some television stations
and Michael pal the head of the FCC blly
assured these thousands of people that
tried to persuade him that this was a
bad idea that it would make no
difference how could it well I think we
have now seen a clear demonstration that
it can make a big difference uh when a
an owner chooses to exercise that
ownership of the public broadcasting you
know Airwaves to manipulate uh a
political a political message the carry
Administration if there is one is
already declared itself to be against
those kinds of changes in the cross
ownership and consolidation of ownership
rules if the Bush Administration is
reelected I think you can expect that
that will not happen certainly Sinclair
and its Brothers very much are for
increasing the consolidation uh that is
not what I would be for it's not what
Carrie is for it's one of the things
that I think is really at stake I think
that we have also in this election moved
from partisanship we use partisanship a
lot now in the in the Med we talk about
how partisan the media have become as
opposed to the sort of tradition of of
objectivity that has been the the
tradition throughout most of the 20th
century in this country but I would
submit that we have taken a very quick
leap only probably in the last year from
something that was partisan to something
that was an active effort to intimidate
I think that there has been a
demonstration um you know on the right
that this was a tactic that had had you
know that worked pretty well I think the
Bush Administration is is has tried it
uh I think that this is on both sides of
the Middle East have tried it now the
left has embraced it and the
traffic the email traffic uh the abuse
of email traffic that uh Finds Its way
to every reporter who is publicly
reporting one thing or another no matter
what the side from whatever the other
side is is something that I think you
all probably would find almost
unimagined able Dan Oaken the public
editor of the New York Times who was at
the shorstein center where I'm director
at the Kennedy School this week and he
talked about how Adam noury the chief
political correspondent of the New York
Times got an email recently from someone
who was on the left who was critical of
the Bush Administration hostile to Iraq
thought that Adam nour's peace was not
sufficiently tough on Bush and said I
hope your son gets his brains blown out
in an AR in a war in in uh that a
Republican president is running running
I mean it was it's that kind of thing
now that was the only part of it that
Dan oaki could publish because the rest
of it couldn't be published at all I can
tell you I get it I know that Mark gets
it I don't know whether you get it Amy
but I can tell you this is a a a
ratcheting up in a big way of the effort
to intimidate because I can tell you
just like terrorism and just like
negative campaigning negative ads why do
they do it because it works because I
can tell you if you're a reporter and
you're out there and you know that if
you write a tough story you're going to
absolutely get your brains beaten out on
the web from people who are going to
write you and call you and who knows
what uh I cannot believe that that's not
going to have an impact I think we've
all seen that there was a uh an effort
to intimidate the media after uh after
911 it worked pretty well I think that
the idea that that is not something that
is going to be ratcheted up after uh the
this election I I fear that is going to
be and I don't know how the journalists
in this country are going to react to it
I think that essentially what there's
been is an effort to discredit the
mainstream media especially I think that
the New York Times uh has certainly uh
contributed to that by its own mistakes
but what the New York Times has done to
its credit as far as I'm concerned is to
admit its mistakes uh to put them out
there to try to deal with them not to
everyone's satisfaction but certainly in
a way that has made them more credible
to me I'm not sure that's the way it's
perceived by other people though I'm not
sure that the loss of credibility that
the mainstream media has now suffered is
not put us in a situation where there is
no Arbiter of truth that everyone on
both sides or most people on both sides
of this political argument accept the
most credible source of information
today I believe is factcheck.org which
was created for this election by the
anenberg foundation uh that that's a
terrible thing in my opinion I think
though that we're moving in a direction
in which there's going to have to be a
mechanism
found either through the mainstream
media either through different standards
for blogs either for this country
growing up uh in journalists growing up
and dealing with these things headon and
straightforwardly uh or else we're going
to be in a in an environment of uh sort
of spiraling efforts to build audiences
at any cost uh and a a very very fevered
and abusive political environment in
which the media will be both the vehicle
for it and the victim of it and uh I'll
leave it at that thank
you thanks Alex Mark is
next uh thank you um nice to see
everybody here um
want to talk about a couple of things um
one point that Alex made that I think is
really worth reiterating about the
intimidation
Factor um and what the sort of media
environment is like these days uh at the
shorstein center where Alex's director
they hosted a um a uh a panel discussion
of the major television anchors on the
eve of the Democratic National
Convention and when it got thrown I
believe got thrown open to the you know
public question and answer period
somebody basically no actually Alex
asked the question about sort of the he
said she said journalism that kind of
dominates campaign coverage in this era
which great example obviously the
swiftbow claims which is that
journalistic organizations particularly
on television no longer feel that their
job is to vet the truth or decide which
side is is making more accurate or
inaccurate claims but simply to air both
claims and that that that represents
good journalism and he asked essentially
you know why there wasn't more
intervention on the part of organization
with journalistic resources um to say no
so and so is more is more accurate on
this one or statistics back this or what
we know suggests this or that and it was
fascinating Dan Rather basically in no
uncertain terms said that in this kind
of environment you are so like and a a
partisan polarized country you are so
likely to be bombarded with angry phone
calls and angry emails should you even
with journalistic backing essentially
air one side or the other's versions of
events that you will quote unquote catch
hell um and that was the word he used
and he said there are fewer and fewer of
us in this business who are brave enough
to do that Peter Jennings for his part
uh talked about an environment in which
somebody came up to him at an airport
and said why don't you get out of this
country you America
hater um and said that he bemoaned the
uh the ability of uh vocal critics of
the media to quote unquote affect the
corporate sweets in news
organizations um giving life to a great
deal of what Alex said on Amy I want to
say one thing about Amy the project for
excellent in journalism which is where
she works and issues the reports and I
actually wrote about the report that she
just discussed with you I picked another
part of it to sort of focus on but it's
a great resource as a media critic we
all intuitively know that we're doing
things wrong most of the time we have to
rely on smart people to sort of
speculate and tell us why we're doing
things wrong but the project for
excellence journalism is one of those
few places that actually creates
empirical evidence of why we're doing
things wrong which is a godsend for
people who have to cover the business
there're actually numbers and content
analyses and we can actually provide
real evidence about why we're doing
things wrong and I'm not I'm not being
factious about that I appreciate it um a
couple of things I wanted to talk about
uh new roles for the established media
is uh the topic here and I'm going to go
a little bit over the some of the
territory that Alex mentioned because I
think it's it's one of the things we
understand and I think we understand
about this campaign is there are
certainly new roles and Powerful roles
for the non-established media in this
campaign when I I I try and sit here and
think about you know the defining moment
that's been created by the traditional
media something that that moved votes a
story that broke something that happened
that that changed the course the
election or or and it's it's very hard
to but I can think of things on in the
non-traditional media that very much
fall into that category Alex mentioned
the blog blog isphere I'm not a huge fan
um it is the democratization of
Journalism um but think of the
phenomenon of what happened with the 60
Minutes um erroneous report on George
Bush's service record based on what
turned out to be if not inaccurate or
phony documents certainly documents of
dubious credibility and will await
Richard thornberg and Lou Bard's verdict
on that the outside panel that's
investigating what happened we that
won't we won't find out what that what
actually happened till after the
election um but think but but he is
absolutely right in that essentially
what happened here was that perhaps the
most
prestigious television news program and
vehicle in the history of the country 60
minutes okay still the gold standard for
television journalism produced a report
from a top anchor and a top producer and
according to a timeline that I saw one
minute before the program actually got
off the air at 8:59 p.m. on September
8th somebody out there in the blog
isphere noting a problem with the the
type face in these memos essentially put
out the word that there was a problem
with this story now what we have here is
an incredible phenomenon I mean you know
all of us in a room if in this room
probably have who who are familiar have
have had a situation where somebody has
some a newspaper television outlet has
has done a story about something you've
actually known something about an
incident a situation a neighborhood a
community okay for most of us the act at
some point the reaction is going to be
no Martha that's not what happened you
know and basically you know up till five
years ago you would have turned to
whoever you're watching TV was and said
that that's wrong those guys got it
wrong I was there well now all you do is
go into your room and turn on the
computer and say the same thing and
essentially what's happened after all
the dominoes fell is that some out there
with a pretty astute knowledge of Smith
Corona typewriters and things like that
essentially is able to create an
earthquake under the longtime CBS anchor
and the most prestigious news program on
television that's democratization um not
everything that's on the blog isphere is
accurate a lot of it is ideologically
motivated but the idea that now every
news organization in America is open to
a Vox pop fact check on every issue that
they write about is a dramatic sea
change in how we do
business um Alex also mentioned Matt
drudge the man who claims to be the Bob
Woodward of modern journalism because he
stole a story from Newsweek that they
had worked on for about a year
indicating that Bill Clinton had an
affair with an intern that's a little
bit like the ants walking away with your
cupcake at a picnic and saying they
baked it um but drudge was also the
source essentially of the one big now
debunked Scandal story that broke in
this campaign which was the John krey
infidelity rumor that hit the the news
stands in February of this year um it
was a story that was actually stopped
because not only did John Kerrey deny it
but actually the woman involved came out
and issued an official denial after a
few days too even in this media
atmosphere two formal denials usually
does it okay um but before that happened
thanks to Matt drudge who started the
rumor and friendly uh uh ideological
allies in behind the talk radio
microphone people like Rush limbo and
Sean Hannity the rumor apparently not
true by all we know got into essentially
every house in America simply by Dent of
this quote unquote New Media combination
of people who don't really care whether
the story is accurate or not but make a
decision based on whether or not it's
out there and whether or not people are
talking about it that story created a
great challenge for the tradition
mainstream media about how to handle
something sort of that sticky and I
actually think that that the mainstream
media pretty much passed by flying
colors um but it was not a story that
was generated in that me that in that
millu at all it was a story that came
essentially from non-traditional media
using very non-traditional
standards another non-traditional factor
in my mind and I use the word media
broadly in this campaign are documentary
filmmakers Michael Moore okay uh and by
the way I put quotes around the word
documentary I think there are people at
Frontline and Nova and places like that
that get a big headache when Michael
Moore calls what he did a
documentary it's it's effective
political propaganda with some truth in
it there's no doubt about that it's a
great movie people probably know that it
did the astounding performed the
astounding feat of actually being the
biggest box office uh earner the weekend
it opened of of any movie period
commercial or otherwise when it first
opened um Michael Moore threw himself
thrust himself dramatically into the
middle of the presidential campaign I
mean when John MC McCain singles you out
at the Republican National Convention
and points to you uh and you are
standing there and the crowd is chanting
four more years and you're going two
more months you know you are a player
now whether or not you know he's G to
have done anything but preached the
converted I don't know but he is not the
only documentary filmmaker that's had an
impact a fellow by the name of Robert
Greenwald with Hollywood credentials um
made a couple of documentaries in this
campaign season one about the war in
Iraq called Iraq uncovered and one that
was a direct attack on another media
organization the Fox News channel of we
report you decide fair and balanced Fame
now home to Bill O'Reilly the uh lawsuit
uh burdened um top rated Prime Time
cable star um called out foxed which was
a direct and somewhat persuasive attack
on the Fox News Channel The Sinclair uh
Broadcasting Corporation which decided
to get involved in overtly partisan
politics in this campaign um used an
anti- carry documentary by a former
Washington Times Reporter as its quote
unquote news material or matter so in a
way that I think there was also for some
of you who may have seen it a fairly I
think of all of them probably the most
impressive and journalistically sound
documentary called control room um about
alzer's coverage of the war in Iraq that
I think may have had some influence on
people who have watched this election
the other area of sort of
non-traditional media obviously is talk
radio now talk radio has been a wholly
owned subsidiary of conservative
politics for a long time certainly since
the late 80s early 90s when the rush
limbo era
flowered um and Bill Clinton was a
Target Rich environment um and across
the talk radio dial conservatives
flourished uh and they have and they
continue to to this campaign the Swift
boat ad the initial ad that was taken
out by the swiftbow Veterans for truth
um raising questions about John K's
wartime efforts and record questions
that were most of which were debunked as
was the group by subsequent reporting in
the New York Times and Washington Post
although it took a while the original ad
buy for that first ad was done in a few
markets in three medium-sized States
period I think it was Ohio Wisconsin and
West Virginia a tiny tiny tiny adby in a
year in which literally tens of millions
of dollars have been spent on television
advertising but yet when the annenburg
people came out and surveyed it they
found that 57% of the people in the
country had either heard about the ad or
seen it that's what's called an echo
chamber effect how does that happen well
it happens because you don't have have
to actually be in the market where they
add airs if people on talk radio and the
cable news networks are going to talk
about it 24 hours a day you just get
that megaphone effect so that sooner or
later whether it's true or false no
longer matters um you're going to have
hurt about it I think there were two
different reasons why talk radio
primarily conservative had an
ideological reason for wanting to
embarrass John KY the cable uh news
networks but Fox notwithstanding as Alex
said have a have a financial reason for
wanting to do it you you've got 247 news
hole a gigantic news hole that that is
infinite so you're going to take any
controversy you can find and and
essentially stretch it out with the he
said she said here's a good idea here's
how journalism Works let's get Mr a to
say the sunrise in the East and Mr B to
say the sunrise in the west and you can
decide based on the persuasiveness of
their arguments and so we won't know
what the final sort of tally on uh how
this campaign uh played out will be
until after Tuesday but if John krey
loses I think there could be some
postmortem that suggest that the Swift
boo vet ad and their campaign against
him was a key factor and the fact that
most of America found out about it is a
function of a media environment that's
fragmented and changed and no longer
needs traditional journalistic standards
to turn a story into something that we
all know and hear about
um the report part of the report that
Amy uh and the project for excellence
and journalism put out this week also
had something also very interesting in
it it it looked at the tone of
coverage um for uh John kery and
President Bush in a two-week period
October 1st through October 14th that
would essentially Encompass the three
debates and it actually found that John
krey by a significant margin had done
better in the press reports that there
had been much more positive coverage of
John KY now as it turns out in 2000 in
this period there was George Bush had
done better than Al Gore although not as
well as John krey had done in 2004 there
are a lot of reasons for this not the
least of which is that at least 40 40%
of the coverage I think was essentially
directly about the debates and then
after the performances in the debates
even coverage of other issues the debate
performan is spilled over into that kind
of coverage and and basically for those
of you who followed even even the snap
polls that were done to gauge sort of
the Public's reaction I mean John carry
was largely seen certainly as the winner
of two of the first in third debate and
he held his own in the second debate so
he was the recipient of positive
coverage for a number of reasons not all
were certain about but certainly a lot
of it had to do with the quality of his
performances in the debate but I
guarantee you that that report is also
going to be seen as fodder for people on
the right who believe that there is
liberal bias in the news media and to me
one of the other outstanding and I don't
mean that in a positive sense but
memorable notable aspects of sort of
where the media is in this campaign is a
partisan polarized electorate okay
beginning to just sort of no longer you
know see everything that is done by the
news media in the context of slant one
way or the other and we have a number of
notable instances conservatives are
Furious conserv cons atives many
conservatives many Bush supporters
believe that the 60 Minutes report which
was certainly sloppy journalistically
and maybe eth e ethically
flawed was essentially a hit job by a
liberal journalist out to smear George
Bush Dan Rather uh has been a a a target
for conservative critics of the media
for a long long time so the right yells
about that um on the other hand the left
has had their sherff F Sinclair
obviously with what they did uh
got overtly involved in partisan
politics a major media organization with
with television 62 television stations
throughout the country uh deciding
essentially to try and influence the
outcome of an election which is a pretty
incredible uh situation now the truth is
Alex in some ways this did turn out well
there was a lot of pressure for the FCC
to get involved I think there are a lot
of First Amendment Advocates who say
that's not the way to go and in some way
shape or form the marketplace actually
reacted to what Sinclair did advertisers
pulled out shareholders threatened the
lawsuit there was tremendous public
pressure on the Sinclair folks and they
actually altered their programming and
really trimmed their sales not because
the government told them to do which
would they would have obviously seen as
another case of sort of overweening
liberal government but because the
marketplace something that they
obviously believe in told them to cut it
out um minor things Mark Halprin is the
political director of ABC News um I
don't know how many of you know know it
but uh he wrote a memo uh to his cohorts
at ABC recently basically saying this uh
yes George Bush and John krey both lie
about each other during the presidential
campaign however it is my belief that
the distortions about John KY are a more
integral part of the Bush campaign than
the other way around and I think we need
to be careful of the idea that we're
going to treat all charges and
countercharges and claims and counter
claims equally so essentially what he
was suggesting was that bu that bush the
bush campaign's quote unquote
distortions about Carrie be closely
scrutinized for accuracy by a news
organization that had the power and the
resources to do so that memo was leaked
obviously I would guess by someone at
ABC who wasn't exactly uh comfortable
with those particular sentiments and
again fodder for the right who believes
that ABC is out to get George Bush on
the other hand Carl Cameron the Fox News
Channel's political correspondent made a
little boo boo earlier in this campaign
when he actually posted a phony story
about John KY on the Fox News website in
which the Massachusetts senator was
quoted as preening and boasting about
his manicure on debate night and uh his
physical appearance and apparently in
this story said hey uh voters and women
should like me I'm a metrosexual George
Bush is a cowboy it was not a true story
it was a madeup story posted on the Fox
News Channel website by someone who had
to apologize
later I would even argue that the uh
that basically that the John kery um as
I said earlier infidelity rumor was
essentially a concoction brewed by a
group of largely conservatives who
really wanted to do in John KY so we've
got enough fodder on the left and the
right not that we need anymore um to
suggest that we've got a sort of a a
very polarized electorate that seems to
be telling us that they don't trust the
concept of objectivity among by the
mainstream media anymore and one of the
organizations that does a lot of polling
in this regard is the Pew Research
Center um and they recently released
some interesting polls um 90% of those
who who responded said that they believe
that journalists often or sometimes let
their own political preferences
influence that way they report news
that's a high number interestingly
enough when the committee for concerned
journalists which is sort of a a brother
or sister organization of the project
for excellence in journalism interviewed
500 of their own journalists and said
tell me what you think some of the
problems in campaign journalism are the
third biggest problem that emerged was
bias in news coverage what's happening
here um one of the things that that I
fear um and that I think may be the one
of the enduring stories of this campaign
and I know Alex doesn't exactly agree
with me we've discussed this a little
bit
is I fear a trend where essentially with
the public saying they have lost
confidence in the objectivity of the
news media which I frankly believe means
that a polarized public no longer wants
to put up with a messenger it does not
agree with okay on potent issues I think
we're moving toward what you know a one
scholar called kind of a cafeteria style
um news consumerism which is the days of
Walter kronite essentially Bringing Down
the tablets from Mount Si every night
and everybody in the country believing
it are long gone and in a universe in
which all of us have more choices than
ever before we're going to start picking
and choosing based on Whose message we
like I'll just give you one example um
and this again comes from a pre research
survey um in the new poll voters who
said they get most of their campaign
news from Fox News a frequent Target of
liberal critics said they support Bush
over Carrie by 70% to
21% at the same time Carrie LED Bush by
67% to 26% among viewers who relied on
CNN and outlet that has been in the
crosshairs of conservative critics so we
all we don't only have red and blue
States now we have red and blue media
okay and that may be a situation that
calms down or goes away once all the
angst and anger and and and everything
else else at a companies this campaign
goes away but I'm not sure I think with
more media choic than ever we are
inexorably moving towards this style of
news use and what that says to me are is
just two things and then I'll quit one
is some smart guy pretty soon who may be
a liberal or may be a conservative is
going to look at the success of the Fox
News Channel which by the way is a
tremendous business success story and
say you know what we need we need a Fox
News channel of the left and that'll be
the next news organization it'll be we
report you decide but Eric alterman will
host all the shows um and and there
won't be any Republicans allowed on and
they'll probably actually do pretty well
in a niche market the other bigger
problem for us as a society is if we go
this way we are going to have fewer and
fewer shared truths everything will be
up for debate
including uh where the sun rises every
morning thank
you
thanks Mark um if folks have either
questions uh or if you want to make a
short statement and ask the panel to
react that's fine use the uh mics
please I'd like to ask about you want
identify yourself too my name is Edwin
Taylor I'm a retired physicist I'd like
to ask about individual
personal
media I understand it was well known
what the Abu grab predations were but I
didn't hear about it and we all heard
about it and were horrified when the
pictures came out those were privately
taken pictures if I am a police officer
who wants to Club a Hispanic or an
africanamerican I'm going to think twice
because somebody's got a little camera
there in addition there's the
individuals who pick up things that
others don't like the Bulge on the back
of George Bush's suit so is there and of
course this is sporadic it is not
professional not organized but it seems
to me to be a significant I think Abu
grab is a significant contribution to
the uh to the uh dialogue that's going
on now Co
Bond well I I think it's important to
bear in mind that the abug grab
photographs were made available through
CBS News um the the the the tradition of
mainstream journalists getting materials
from individuals like those photographs
that were taken that's not something new
on the other hand I think you're quite
right that the idea of a world of people
with you know instant cameras and and uh
videos and phones that will take
pictures and things like that suggest
that um there's going to be a very you
know they're having now an increasing
problem of people going into locker
rooms and taking pictures of people and
putting them on the web things like that
I mean they're kind of odd things that
are starting to pop up as problems that
we've never really had before because
people can be in a situation where they
don't know they're having a photograph
taken and a photograph can be taken and
put on the web and spread virally in a
matter of hours so I I think that you're
right that it is a uh a new world of
warning that makes everybody who wants
to participate uh as a journalist or a
recorder or a photographer or a blogger
or anything else that certainly that
certainly can happen but there is also
the problem that goes along with that of
a kind of cacophony of uh uh without any
real uh you know with without anyone
there acting as gatekeeper and I think
that what we're probably going to come
to rather quickly is the recognized need
that Gatekeepers have had and still
continue to uh to serve if uh if they do
their job properly but they've got to be
Gatekeepers that people have confidence
in and as Mark said um we're now in a
world in this country at the moment of
of sort of separate realities and it's
very hard to find a an honest broker for
information if uh if you're talking
about two separate realities that don't
really seem to have anything in common
much I'll give you just one one quick
example um at the Boston Globe that I
know about which is after the uh last
week's uh unfortunate tragic incident in
the wake of the celebration after the uh
American League Championship Series that
left one student dead in this uh city um
the the photographs at the globe
actually used were taken by not their
photographer but by a student who went
to the event and essentially uh you know
just recorded what happened um and I I
actually interviewed him for the story
and he he was very torn about whether he
was ever wanted those photographs to
actually I mean he did offer them to
Globe we used them but the truth was his
motivation was not in any way shape or
form professional what he really said to
me was the only reason I took those
photographs and brought them to the
globe was because I wanted to make sure
there was going to be accountability so
in some ways it was classic sort of
Citizen
journalism other
questions I have um just sort of a
series of themes that you all brought up
but um just to discuss them maybe in a
in a different way so I think that
there's some issues regarding the
structure of our democracy that affect
theu
the what's happening in the electorate
and the media one of those is the two-
party system which I think helps people
see the world in black and white you
have to choose you're either one or the
other you don't have a variety of
options and the fact that people are
often hereditary voters you're you are
what your parents are and the parties
can count on voters in that sense maybe
less now than they used to another theme
is
um I'm just gonna check my little things
here I get in front of microphones
um the access of journalists so you you
mentioned that journalists are bullied
by the public but then again their
access in Washington is determined
whether by whether or not they're nice
to powerful people if you write a mean
story about somebody you might not be
asked back to the next press conference
and so what does that mean for
journalists too I mean they might be
afraid of emails but at the same time
they have to give up their job Integrity
in order to do their job um so that
that's another question and the other
thing is um personality politics we
always vote for people and that helps us
be a bit more frivolous I think if we
voted on issues we might have a
different reaction to discussions of
policy the fact that we're always voting
for one candidate or another helps us
you know might help the media and the
electorate think more about people's
hair dues than about their what the
policy points are so if you could just
have some things to say on those I
wanted to add to your middle question
there which is about this question of
official domination of the news and if
you could comment on on how many ways
and to what degree it matters that the
Press can be hurt by officialdom uh the
times had a story a few weeks ago months
ago on uh one of their folk who was
covering the justice department who had
his credentials withdrawn because the
the story was implying while the
credentials are withdrawn because he was
covering the justice department ways
that weren't welcome in the Justice
Department of course the administration
said that wasn't true there's a long
tradition in in analysis of press
coverage especially of defense and
Foreign Affairs that that's his Zone
where um uh official domination of the
news is very pronounced because there's
a single Source if you're a journalist
you got one place to go to get your news
which is the dod and the state
department or if you're covering Iraq
you have to go to the CPA in Iraq um so
what about that and then the parallel
issue is um bribing the Press I'm I'm
I'm running away with your questions
here but this question of um deal
cutting between the press and uh
official if um you continue with
consolidation of the media to what
extent are we going to see sort of
sweetheart relationships which have been
alleged for example between Clear
Channel and uh the media there's been
some argument saying that because Clear
Channel got real big and became a player
that could actually negotiate with the
American government there was a
negotiation and some understanding that
Clear Channel would in exchange for
being uh consolidated would cover the
news in a way that was friendly so
comments
to speak to the um issue of um relying
on officials for your information what
happens if you don't get it we did do a
look at um coverage during the war in
Afghanistan and one of the things we saw
which was quite interesting we tried to
get at this question of how much of the
information that's getting out is
information that is um on the side of
the administration is coming with the
with the Viewpoint that the
Administration has on the war versus
Outsider information
um even foreign you know from
Afghanistan and what we found was a huge
preponderance of information that was
coming from the administration's point
of view um and then as as the as the war
continued less and less information
overall and what happened was the
journalists by and large had one source
to go to the Pentagon and during that
war the Pentagon really cracked down and
wasn't giving out very much information
um and journalists then had very little
to report they had little else to go to
part of that is due to the fact that um
foreign bureaus aren't very common
anymore and many journalists um don't
have a a big Rolodex of sources to go to
um for information of that nature they
didn't know who else to turn to to get
reliable information so they were
relying on the Pentagon and when that
Pentagon isn't giving out information
whether it's because they don't like you
or for another reason um it certainly
affects the coverage and the information
that citizens are going to get
I would only say in addition to that
that there's obviously always tension
between journalists and sources and the
administration uh and the journalists
and so forth I mean it's a tug OFW it
always is uh this I think uh this
Administration most journalists believe
is the most hostile and the most willing
to punish journalists uh but you know so
be it I mean I think that that's just
part of the game I think that the
journalists from the major news
organizations have uh you know since the
war in Iraq um Turned and they began
really doing their job I think that they
have been you know they have been doing
their job and I mean the New York Times
is very unpopular with the Bush
Administration and David Sanger who's
their White House correspondent had a
hell of a hard time getting George Bush
to sit down with him okay that that
that's part of it but I think that the
the sophistication of people who consume
news is important and I think that they
need to be on guard they need to be
aware of of the concept of of uh you
know of having intimidation or or
payoffs or sweetheart deals and all
these kinds of things all of these
things are there I think that what is
what has been added to that mix though
is this sort of extra party ideological
brow beating that I think is taking a
toll that's a different kind of toll
from the one you're talking
about uh I'll address a couple of these
points really quickly um in terms of
sources and you and relying on the
government I think one of the sort of
interesting things about the times
famous page A10 apology or sort of
editor note saying essentially that they
were way too gullible in printing and
believing uh you know reports of
possession of weapons of mass
destruction by Saddam Hussein and the
runup to the war which obviously was a
major feeling on the part of the media
to do a better job on that essentially
if you read what they said what they
were saying is is there's a sort of
circular you know circular relationship
here you know the administration
provided dubious sources we talked to
dubious sources we wrote dubious stories
you know it sort of went around in a in
a circle there and and it's they took
responsibility for it as they should
have uh the sweetheart relationships the
the question you raised you know it
would be pretty hard to prove that a
news organization is making a specific
decision because it's got an ongoing
negotiation with the FCC or be although
obviously there are issues of interest
that they do have with the government
but I think the perhaps the more more
salian point is look at the makeup of
these organizations they are you know
journalism organizations media Outlets
are not owned by companies that now are
just in the journalism business if they
were that would be their core product
their only product they would live and
die with it okay um and and they and
that would be where the reputation is
Media Outlets are owned by companies
that own everything they are in 50
different businesses they are in a
hundred different businesses the
journalism piece of that company is just
in many cases is just one line on a
ledger sheet what is that right right
well yeah television and but magazines I
mean Time Warner um but primarily
television um and what does that mean it
means when a war comes somebody may be
thinking we can't afford to be unpopular
because it could affect a whole range of
our businesses that's something to think
about um and finally on the issue of
sort of personal this is one of my
classic
whiny cranky complaints about political
journalism political journalism is done
election coverage is done by very good
people really I mean in my paper I think
that but the truth is they're done by
people who understand election
journalism and understand politics which
means they understand polls they
understand ads they understand
Consultants they understand strategy
they understand what works and doesn't
work political journalism campaign
journalism is very rarely written by
people who actually have expertise in
the issues that are at Play Why when
Healthcare becomes an issue isn't the
science reporter covering it you know
why when the environment both sides you
know Bush says he's a good Steward in
the environment and and Carrie says no
you're not why isn't the environmental
reporter covering that aspect of the
campaign you know for that matter why
isn't the drama critic covering the
debates um so part of the problem there
is really you don't have the right
people necessarily covering the things
they know the most
about you folks have uh questions
comments than you uh excuse me I'm Henry
Ruben I'm a professor of sociology and
media studies at tus um and part of my
question has to do with young people who
I see in my classroom um who um don't
have a sense of of
time uh that you were referring to to do
in-depth reporting uh at the mainstream
papers um when they do their research
papers for me they go to the web um and
they think they're doing research when
they uh when they look at my reading my
syllabus and they see something that was
before 2000 they think it's ancient
news um how would you
suggest
um addressing this sense of
time uh and how it's changing the news
cycle uh for um reaching out to young
people and getting them to understand
the difference between say a mainstream
source
and a Blog um how do we um uh how can we
look to a future when these young people
are raised in in this Digital Society
they don't see anything else they they
will be the next Generation uh if if
they don't understand the difference I
think we're
lost um so how would you approach um uh
teaching young people how to
discriminate between uh different kinds
of new
standards um I think you've put your
finger on I think it's a very good
question and a and a difficult question
because there's no you know young people
are raised uh on a different set of
behaviors than uh than someone my age or
or even your age I think that the worst
thing that American journalism does
is uh tell
episodically what's going on
without creating genuine context for
things and I think honestly that they
really missed the boat here I think most
people really like a good story I mean
they go to the movies uh they like a
good story well one of the best stories
and one of the most fascinating stories
is going back to find out what really
happened to to something and I think
that a news
organization that for instance the cable
news people or the mainstream newspapers
for that matter or any newspaper ought
to make it a practice a common practice
uh a feature really of picking a topic
of going back and saying this is what we
reported but this is what really
happened I mean journalism as someone
said is done on Horseback it really is
the very rough first draft and almost
always in my experience it's wrong it's
wrong in some important ways usually but
we don't really go back we may go back
and correct the specific errors or if
it's some you know particularly
explosive moment we may go try to set
the record straight after a fashion but
we really don't go back and say you know
this is what we thought was going to
happen this is what we said was going to
happen this did not happen what happened
instead was this and this is why in
other words allow the media allow news
to be the vehicle for teaching about
what happened and also as a cautionary
tale how you should interpret and read
the news that you're getting and I think
to a certain extent this would allow um
would allow the students that you have
to to really kind of focus on that I one
of the things that I do for the class
that I teach is to try uh to well I
assign my students as their main
research paper going to some incident
and really digging in to what happened
how it was reported why it was reported
that way really trying to find out um
how it was reported relative to what
later became
clear something closer to the truth was
I I would subscribe to that but I think
it's a you know if you think that you're
going to get kids to um easily be
interested in these things probably not
but I still think it's possible
certainly it's worth
trying
uh not as a not as a plug but as
something that might help as a teaching
Aid um we've started something on our
website which we call etymologies which
are very much along the lines um of what
you were talking about where we take a
story one of our staffers who's a
journalist takes a story and traces it
from the very beginning the very first
appearance in the press and traces it
all the way through exactly what
happened and we did it for Jessica Lynch
we did it for Abu grab um and that may
be you know a helpful tool to offer to
students and then suggest that they you
know take a story and try to do that on
their own as well um uh but I certainly
think that that's the way to get young
people to appreciate depth and
understanding um as well as looking back
at at some of the um journalism of the
past that was certainly done through
great shoe leather
reporting just one one further thing I
mean when you're doing this one of the
things you can do is tell your students
that they should identify specific
journalists specific stories and then go
back and ask the journalist why they did
what they did I think you'll find
frequently journalists are willing to
talk about things like that uh
especially with students who are you
know interested in journalism and it
really can be quite uh helpful to both
the reporter and to the to the
student in most cases journalists will
blame their
editor I want to ask Amy when you do the
acknowledges how often does it in fact
turn out as Alex says that the first
draft was
significantly uh far from the final
draft
mostes meily stories
where you know and primarily it's
stories that turned out to have be
problematic in one way or another but um
certainly the beginning and as it you
know the first appearance of it was not
what ended up being the truth in the
end for instance I have every reason to
believe that last night's score was
probably incorrect I think when
they over here hi uh John hackinson all
of you in your initial presentations
painted a pretty bleak picture of what
was going on with you know our world and
especially print media and how it's much
less successful at covering real issues
uh not completely in of its own fault
but to some extent its own fault so
where do we go from here what Solutions
do you see our world evolving to solve
these problems or are we just completely
doomed there's an easy one well if you
got the impression I was saying that the
problem is the print media and not the
other media you misunderstood what I was
saying no no not at all but that the
other media caused the print media to
have this problem and the print media
has that problem now it's not of its own
making I agree well I mean I I consider
the the print media especially the major
surviving major newspapers to be the
only real journalistic serious
journalistic resource and also NPR and a
few a few isolated other cases but I
think that I mean it's a very
interesting question because obviously
you're you're right I do think there's a
very big problem I think the problem is
that the there's a dwindling amount of
money that's going to be spent on real
reporting that I think is the core
problem that's the worst problem because
that I mean when I say reporting I mean
reporting on serious things reporting on
politics policy issues things that are
not ones that have a natural uh you know
Advertiser based like sports and
celebrity reporting and so forth and I
think that that what you're going to
find is something that you've already
started to see which is that news
organizations are not going to be
willing to F foot the bill to do this
kind of reporting so it's going to be
foundations it's going to be you know
universities it's going to be endowed
reporter ships it's going to be
volunteers who you know will will
support somebody going to do a piece of
work I mean I think that there are
things now that are cropping up that are
going to be considered to be in the
public service which have been in the
past part of the sort of you know
contract that the news organizations in
this country had with the public that
they are now basically increasingly
walking away
from uh you know that is one of the sort
of the occupational hazards happen when
you're a media critic which is that you
depress your audience all the time and
you know the joke I've always made is
that there'll be you know always said
that cockroaches would be the only
species to survive you know a nuclear
Holocaust and I actually say it's
cockroach and media critics because
somebody would have to describe how
poorly the of the world was covered um
so we do have tend to sort of be a drag
when you listen to us which is just
because that's our sort of n our line of
work but two upbeat things I would say
is in a increasingly confusing world
when it comes to information um and what
what to believe there is a backlash for
you know refereeing for somebody to get
to the bottom of it for and and if it's
slowly occurring it will occur I think
in greater numbers and people will start
to rely on on Brands and brands and
names and people they ultimately think
they can trust to make sense hopefully
of some of the more confusing elements
of the world I one of the interesting
things that happened since 911 is the
reemergence of two reporters Sai hirs
and Bob Woodward who are essentially
relics from the 60s um you know both men
you know in their 60s I believe
Woodward's in his 60s now um you know
who were sort of old style reporters who
have come back in Vogue the other thing
I would say that's that's somewhat
positive is that news organizations and
it may not happen in television or it
may but it certainly has to happen in
print need to maintain their standards
and and and I will say this in the
aftermath of the Jason Blair
particularly and Scandal and the Jack
Kelly scandal at USA Today I can tell
you personally that the sort of the
rules the regulations and the standards
of the Boston Globe and a lot of other
papers in the country have been
toughened um and so rather than sort of
you know in some way sort of falling
into a hey everybody else is doing it
quick and dirty it's you know it's it's
much tougher now than it was when I
started to get an anonymous source into
the Boston Globe um you know somebody
making an homm attack without putting
their name on it um unless they're in
Washington well even then even then
actually so um that's the good
news over
here my name is Dave leid I'm a social
psychologist Alliance for democracy I'm
concerned about the uh whether or how uh
surveys
research can be misleading or the
reporting of survey research can be
misleading um I particularly thinking
about the uh the responses of the Bush
supporters that Alex Jones
mentioned um to policy issues and how
wrong they had it about what Bush was
really uh doing or was standing for and
I just wonder whether the these
surveys uh asked follow-up questions in
any depth about why people believed that
bush supported environmental good
environmental measures and so
forth
um I actually do have an answer for that
it's kind of fascinating it's one of the
it's actually rather encouraging in a
way the reason these Bush supporters
believed that he supported these issues
is because they supported those issues
if you tended to believe that supporting
the Kyoto treaty was a good idea you
believe George Bush thought it was a
good idea if you thought that the
comprehensive test band treaty was a
good idea you projected that onto George
Bush and it suggests to me that a lot of
the reasons people are voting for George
Bush are not because they agree with him
on policy questions at least not on some
policy questions uh and that the way
people feel about ISS issues themselves
in this country is something that we
share more than we seem to feel like we
do in these appalling red and blue
states which I think is one of the great
disservices of our media to create I
feel like this idea of dividing the
country into red and blue States is
becoming more pernicious and more really
uh damaging to us all the time because
it's I mean it makes sense in a way
because of the electoral college but I
think that basically if you're red and
living in a blue state or vice versa you
feel like you've practically ceased to
exist as far as the rest of your
countrymen are concerned and I I think
that's a bad idea but what I'm saying is
that the people who this this these this
panel of the rather the survey was
trying to get at did ask them those
questions and that seemed to be what was
going
on just a word on surveys in general and
your concern about their use um I think
there there are two things that have
been happening in in in the world of
surveys over the last several years one
is a extreme proliferation of them every
organization doing their own survey
putting out their own numbers um um as
well as the way the surveys are being
used I think those are two issues and
two different issues um I I do think
that journalists over the last four
years um perhaps have gotten a lot more
educated in the use of polls and
understanding what makes a solid poll a
solid poll the total number of people
you've surveyed the geographic
distribution the race distribution
journalists that call about our content
analysis now more and more are asking me
you know what was my um um sampling
error what was my you know other
questions which I think five years ago
they weren't as educated asking about so
I think they are getting better about
picking and choosing which kinds of
surveys they're reporting on at least in
the mainstream press in the established
press I think in in some of the more
partisan areas of information uh giv
uh they choose because it's the numbers
they want to put out and so it's up to
the individual to be careful about what
they uh consume and what they believe in
addition to that there's um the purpose
of surveys in the first place it's not
to uh they're not to be used as facts
they're not to be used as the answer
it's the same thing with content
analysis all of it is meant as
indicators as ways to help guide our
thinking to help educate us and Andrew
cohut who's the head of the peer
research center would be the first one
to preach that and to say that too many
times surveys are used in this day and
age as the answer as what's as you know
the answer to what's happening as
opposed to something to help guide our
thinking over here more
questions thank you Steve Brown MIT
staff my question relates to uh rational
ignorance and how we could help the
voters more constructively practice
rational
ignorance uh uh I wonder if the coverage
that we're seeing in the changes from
2000 to 2004 are driven by the relative
campaigns belief that the majority of
Voters don't feel equipped to decide how
to vote based on a candidate's skills
and positions and instead make their
decisions of who they feel comfortable
with for example Good Morning America
interview of a voter asking why she was
for Bush and she said I'd really like to
have him over to over to dinner better
than I would like to have carry so the
question is how can we help voters
increase their self-confidence so they
feel equipped to make their decision
based on skills and issues and not just
on who they feel comfortable
with I I'll just tell you what I think I
don't know that I don't really know that
there is a Ser great answer I have the
things that I have read about this
election are that the people who are for
Georgia GE Bush not all of them
obviously but many of them voted for
George Bush in the year 2000 uh made a
kind of an emotional commitment to
George Bush after 911 made another
emotional commitment to George Bush over
the invasion of Iraq and find it very
difficult to go back on that I mean
basically to say you know I was wrong
three times I guess here I mean that's
it was a it's a it's a human thing and I
think that that what you're what you're
getting at is a very important problem
because I think it gets to the heart of
some of the frustration of people on all
sides of questions they don't understand
why if this information is out there
people don't change their minds and
frequently you'll have situations where
the information simply won't matter I
mean the the New York Times and every
other news organization in the country
can be beating you know the devil out of
Bill Clinton over the Monica Lewinsky
Affair and all the other things but his
approval ratings remain very high it
doesn't just work for George Bush it's
something that that uh you know people
attach to a leader especially it makes a
big difference and I think my my
intuition here and I speak of it purely
that way is that much of the support for
George Bush is emotional support whereas
much of the opposition to George Bush uh
is rooted in a more of a more more of an
analytical kind of way of looking at
things and that may flatter I'm one of
those people on that side of the
argument but I think that the the fact
is that that this survey found that the
people at least who were for John KY had
a pretty accurate rendering
understanding of what his positions were
I think that uh that speaks here but I
think that we are in a particularly
volatile emotional environment and uh I
don't know that there's anything that
you could see tomorrow in the newspaper
that would make you change your mind
about who you're going to vote for be it
Bush or carry uh I'm trying to imagine I
mean would if there was a terrorist
attack that piece of news might change
things if maybe for some people if uh if
you know if uh some if some there was
some big development in the war on
terror but I mean if you were told for
instance something terrible about George
Bush or terrible about John krey if you
were supporting either of those people
uh How likely would you be to change
your mind if you're for John krey you
could easily imagine a George Bush
person changing their mind but if I told
you that John krey actually had you know
beaten up his wife in his first marriage
and put her in the hospital would that
make you change your mind about voting
for John krey I I I doubt it and I think
it works you know people are are fixed
they make a decision once that decision
is made it's hard to go back and George
Bush benefits from the fact that a big
part of this country made the decision
to support him you know over the past
several years and that's very hard to to
turn
around I would just I mean there are a
lot of factors that go into why people
select and and you do hear things like
I'd like to have a beer with I think
he'd be the better guy to have a beer
with I hear things like I don't want
this guy in my TV set for the next four
years you know and and be before we make
fun of that the only the only thing I'd
say is sometimes I think the American
elector looks and appears to be very
sophisticated you mentioned Clinton for
example um you know I think a poll done
during the second you know his second
campaign against Bob Dole was was
actually fascinating in that a majority
of the Americans pulled said that they
actually believe that Bob Dole was the
better man in traditional moral sense
but they wanted Clinton to be president
and and for the first time I mean you
know you're old enough you can remember
that Nelson Rockefeller was never going
able to run for president because he had
an amicable divorce you know um now he
had a guy who was having you know who
had had all his uh his own personal
problems and the American public had
said you know what we can separate
between an effective president and what
we think of the character issues the
other thing that's tricky about picking
a president is you can't simply it's
it's very difficult and tricky to go on
a checklist of issues on a strictly
intellectual way and strictly and and
and school yourself about the candidates
and say okay I like this guy better
because I like what he says go back and
see what GE what kind of candidate
George Bush was in 2000 a humble foreign
policy against nation building okay we
all thought this was going to be an
inward looking small boore presidency
now no one could have predicted 9/11 but
maybe we we ought to have known more
about George Bush the man to know that
he would have thrown all those tenants
away and adopted a a a diametrically
opposed position Visa the world if we
had understood him better um Jimmy
Carter you know I mean it's it was one
thing his presidency was one thing to
understand the issues about Jimmy Carter
it was another thing for the American
public to be able to predict you know
how he how poorly he would cope with
adversity or how poor a leader he would
be with the country in moments of
adversity so you never want a situation
where you know you want a kind of a
league of Voters checklist where
everybody says well I like him on this
this this this and this because the
presidency doesn't work
out over
here my name is Norm farell I teach
ethics at Boston University uh very
appreciative of the panel and I want to
pick up on some of the questions that
have been you know already offered uh I
have some great concerns about this
polarization that Alex talks about and
it seems to me there something that's
easier to cover when it's deeply
polarized and it's also easier to cover
if you can identify with a person rather
than an issue particularly if the issue
is complex and and I think one of the
difficulties is is and whether it's the
mainline Media or not when you get a
two-page report in the New York Times
extensive report uh you know how how do
we make complexity more accessible
accessible because the issues are very
complicated that's one of the reasons
why the one liners work so well I mean
you can latch on to something and it's
it's TR it's deeply troubling to me and
a lot of others because when the issues
are complex simply simplifying doesn't
make them less complex but the problem
is they're not accessible and I'm
wondering the role of the media all
aspects of the media I'm very just
concerted that the proliferation of
different kinds of Technologies is
leading toward greater polarization
rather than you know the kind of
reconciliation that's going to be needed
after Tuesday because this country is
going to be deeply divided no matter who
wins and the question is what kinds of
things can be done and how do we
move well I think that again this is a
very you put your finger on a very
important problem as far as I'm
concerned certainly I think that
Americans yearn for being united at the
same time they vote with their feet in
terms of their attention uh for or
conflict uh I think that for most
Americans if you ask them where they are
politically they have some line that
they have drawn in their own minds and
they're on one side of that and or
they're on the other side of that I mean
it's something that most Americans are
clear in that sense about but what
happens when you find yourself making
that choice in our media environment is
that you may be on this side of the line
but you suddenly find yourself abruptly
shoved all the way over here for the
people who speak for you or if you're on
this side of the line it works similarly
the other way it's sort of the the
crossfire effect I mean everything is
put in the most extreme terms and the
idea of Reason discourse while it may
sound appealing is not something that
draws the ratings what draws the ratings
are O'Reilly and Hannity and Combs and
Crossfire and things like that I don't
know how many of you had the Good
Fortune to see John Stewart absolutely
deadly seriously bringing those two
clowns on CrossFire to heal about what
they were doing and what it was costing
the country um but he was it was one of
it was one of John Stewart's very very
best moments and I think that the the
problem is that in the economic
environment I'm talking about with this
battle for ratings and this Furious
economic you know drive to get as big an
audience as you can if people think it
will attract an audience then that's
what they're going to do and the
television wisdom is that anything that
is not full of conflict and sharp and
Edge and uh you know and and harsh
language and that kind of in-your-face
behavior uh that's boring if it's not
like that and that that's a that's a
terrible thing but we say we don't like
it but then we certainly do watch
it very David thorburn MIT uh in my life
lifetime it seems it seems to me
certainly in my adult lifetime this is
the the election in which the role of
religion has been the most powerful and
I wonder whether uh the that qu that
that problem is something that the panel
would like to address it seems to me a
very significant factor that hasn't yet
been really talked about directly um and
maybe help explain helps to explain this
terrible polarization we're talking
about the way the kind the kind of the
the role not only that religion plays in
a kind of explicit sense but the
implicit assumptions that voters may be
making about religious questions that
are connected to
religion Mark's got to
go you want do
[Applause]
it uh I'll try to address that briefly
and then had one comment on the issue of
complexity in the news um I think
religion is another area of of
polarization but one that perhaps is not
as um conscious is not as allowed to be
as much on the surface as we see it's so
easy now for people to grab on to blue
versus red um whereas religion is
something that's more of an underlying a
lot of people aren't sure exactly what
they feel about it exactly how much they
want it to be attached to where the
country goes to the role of this leader
to decisions that are made I think
there's there's a big question mark in
our country about how closely attached
religion should be to politics it's an
area that's continued to um receive
debate over and over again so um the
question of of John KY and his
willingness or or lack thereof to
discuss religion um is an important
indicator that that's an area where
people are not comfortable are not sure
um the extent to which they're making um
their voting decisions based on that I'm
not sure about I don't know that survey
data would suggest that religion is tied
so much to um how people are voting
certainly there's a core group and I
think perhaps eight years ago the
Evangelical rise was a greater influence
than it is in the election today um in
general the issues of complexity and and
covering those areas in the news is one
where again I think the um availability
of the new technology what kinds of
things are offered by 20 by having 24
hours to fill with information by having
a you know a Blog that you could put out
all kinds of information on I mean the
the capability to cover complex issues
is enormous today there's all kinds of
background all kinds of Graphics you can
develop all kinds of ways that you can
explain complex issues to individuals
especially those that are interested in
them and unfortunately as Alex says the
money isn't there people aren't willing
to devote the time even to develop those
let alone test them or experiment with
them I I have one thought about the
religion thing that um that I don't know
whether will you'll agree with it or not
but I think to a certain extent it's a
Canard in this respect it's not that I
don't think the evangelicals are one of
Carl rove's aces in the whole I mean
obviously that this is this has been one
of the things that George Bush has used
very well uh he has great support among
evangelicals and many evangelicals uh
you know who are poor people in the
South or black people who theoretically
would have other reasons theor you would
think to vote for a Democrat will vote
for George Bush uh because of that
however I think the idea that the issue
of religion is is becoming the the Trump
of everything else the thing that is
going to be the uh the the only real
meaningful criteria for a lot of people
uh I just don't buy it at least it's not
been proved to me yet what I mean is
this we have had this war without real
cost there has been no tax there has
been no draft we have except for the
people who have lost their own loved
ones or had their you know relatives and
Friends serving we've basically all been
watching it but none of us have been
touched by it really not at all if
George Bush were to say you know I need
a draft in order to to wage this War I
think his prospects of being reelected
no matter what he said about God's Will
and how God told him to do the draft I
think they would go plummeting through
the floor because I think that the the
thing that George Bush has tried to do
that's been that has sort of empowered
this this issue of Evangelical support
is that he's created an environment in
which there is no cost that the
Evangelical voters would perceive to be
one that did Trump even that that now
Evangelical beliefs will trust Will Will
trump an environment of relative you
know
economic unhappiness but it's Far Cry
from a depression we've got 5%
unemployment that's really not that's
pretty normal really in our country so
we're not in a situation that has put to
a test how powerful this religious
conviction is as opposed to something
else and until we really see it stand up
and knock a really powerful disincentive
in the other direction out um I'm not
persuaded that it's going to be the the
sort of super powerful force uh that I
know some people fear it
is over
here hi I'm alandro an Italian
journalist and a student I have a
question about the political system of
electing the president of United States
in in Colorado people are are going to
vote for a proportional distribution of
the state votes to elect the president
of United
States I don't know maybe this
referendum will pass many other states
in the future reform of The Winner Takes
so system uh change for a proportional
distribution of their own votes for the
president and may this change all median
system and may one day
all Medias uh stop dividing your country
in red States and blue States thank
you um I think that the you know there's
been an opposition to the electoral
system that we have in this country for
a long time and back in the 1960s there
was really a about 1969 there was an
effort that I mean the Senate passed uh
a law that would uh that had it gone
forward uh would have uh would have
really brought it would have had to pass
two-thirds of the Senate and then be R
been ratified it would have changing the
Constitution so it's not an easy thing
to do um but the uh I just heard
literally today uh Alex kesar who's on
the faculty of the Kennedy School talk
about this and he put it to the um to
you know interest groups not necessarily
on the basis of small states but purely
on the basis of now uh political
entities on both sides
that would perceive their short-term
interest to be damaged by either doing
it proportionately or or keeping it the
way it is I mean I think that the uh if
the Democrats in a particular State
believe that it's uh likely that they're
going to continue to control the
politics of that state they're not going
to want it to go away because it gives
them a disproportionate power relative
to the electoral system so uh I asked or
someone asked Alex kesar what
circumstance would make it ripe for
Change and he said that if this year
George Bush should win the popular vote
but John KY win the electoral vote and
therefore the presidency then basically
the Democrats would have had it happen
to them once the Republicans would have
had it happen to them once and maybe
they do something about
it I'd like to ask a couple of questions
first I'd like to uh press Alex further
and invite Amy also to talk about this
question of um how
official uh carrots and sticks affect
coverage Alex you were saying hey the
threat to ex exclude a a Troublesome
journalist from press conferences is all
part of the game and this pulling and
Hauling is part of the warp and woof of
the relationship but that still leaves
the question how much influence does
that have on press coverage how
frightening is the threat of retaliation
from the state uh to journalists
recently we had a interesting event on
the on the net that many people noticed
which was a Wall Street Journal reporter
in in Baghdad sent an email to some of
her friends uh about the situation and
um her email was a lot more gloomy it
painted a much gloomier picture than the
mainstream presses painting uh she was
talking about how basically she couldn't
do her job anymore and how her life was
in danger all the time and that fits the
sort of I I listen a lot to folk were in
a rock and it fits what they tell me
that things are worse over there than
the media generally has painted um s
grazing the question why is this some of
my folks who are close to it have been
say telling me that since July 1st since
the Handover um um the American
operation over there has basically uh
stopped updating their websites um has
stopped holding press conferences
they're pretending as if uh the war is
now um in the Iraqis hands and they're
telling journalist hey you want to cover
this war go talk to the Iraqis it
sources are dried up and so uh the
amount of coverage on the situation is
diminished uh and well in any event I
guess I'm saying can you explain what
many people saw as the gap between what
this Wall Street Journal reporter was
describing and um uh the mainstream
coverage of the situation there second
question I had was okay sure um I would
I would say that what you've just
described is the difference between a
reported story and a
Blog a Blog has all the appearance of
being the heartfelt belief of the person
writing but it is not based necessarily
on reporting
information it's not sourced it's not um
necessary to demonstrate that it's true
you're simply saying it's your opinion
it's what you think U and it's very very
persuasive and believable it's also very
very subject to manipulation I mean what
if you found out after the fact that
that was written by a PR firm that
somehow managed to get that done I mean
all I'm saying is that the the the best
thing about blogs is that their
believability is so high but that is
because people believe that the people
writing them are at least speaking
sincerely the sincerity of bloggers if
not the accuracy it's not so much that
people believe that bloggers are
accurate but they do believe they're
sincere I think that is a dangerous
thing for us to imagine is always true
or even mostly true in an environment
when there is as much you know talent
and PR out there as there is right now
and uh and and that this is such a
beautiful opportunity especially at a
remove and often anonymously to take
advantage of that what what a reported
story is is uh something that has to
adhere to journalistic standards uh in
the Wall Street Journal which is the
news organization we're talking about
you can't get stuff in the Wall Street
Journal without you know without it
being supported by evidence and you are
held accountable for that and if you
turn out to be reporting erroneously
then theoretically you can be called on
it now
does that mean that there's been
sometimes uh Mis misrepresentation or a
uh you know a a diminished um uh you
know sort of
uh a story that that does not capture
the reporter's vision of what they have
experienced uh and in the same way in
their reporting as it is in their
personal letters home absolutely but I
can tell you as a reporter that you know
a reporter writing home is writing about
a personal experience that may or may
not reflect the reality beyond their you
know worm's eye view it's not something
they have to prove it's something that
they feel and while it may be persuasive
to you when you get it and read it as a
as a personal missive from someone you
you know intuitively maybe you know or
in this case who you you're inclined to
believe it's not the same thing as
reported journalism and I would caution
that you know it is dangerous to believe
that um that journalism is inferior to
uh such a such a piece of information I
am an old-fashioned person perhaps in
this but I would trust the journalism
more I'll add one example and then
another Point um I I think another
example of the Wall Street Journal um uh
case is what happened with embedded
reporting certainly it offered a lot in
terms of visuals in terms of feeling
like we were experiencing to a certain
extent what the soldiers and other
people there were going through but what
we found out after you'd go through a
slew of watching these embedded
reporters is that a lot of the facts
were wrong um they would announced
incorrect numbers of deaths incorrect
other information which the Pentagon
hadn't released yet the reporters were
saying that because they were there and
they were seeing things but it hadn't
gone through the checks of reporting so
whether there was some tremendous um
journalism um through embedded reporting
in the sense of giving us some
experience and visuals and color we
couldn't otherwise get the facts that
certainly wasn't the best place to go
for the facts um and in terms of the
back and forth you're talking about
between government officials and and the
reporters um I would just add um to
remember that the administration those
that are in in the public positions have
to sustain their Public Image as well
and if they aren't speaking to the Press
um the public doesn't usually like that
so there's you know they often feel
compelled and know that there's a
certain amount of information they have
to give out so it is a tension it's like
the three branches of government you
know there's a constant tension of going
back and forth I think that does need to
be respected to a certain
extent over
here I'm Norman beer just a old grad and
uh I like to comment that
it's remarkable how little difference
there is between oh probably what's
going on in Iraq and what we know um if
you went back to World War II you find a
completely different situation nothing
of uh that uh it comes out of a rock
would have ever come out from the front
in in the Europe or uh the Pacific in
those days because it was very much a
necessity it was felt to be a necessity
to maintain the propaganda to maintain
the courageous image because we were
getting beaten around the head and ears
for a couple of years before we began to
take hold and I think that um um it is
remarkable how much information we're
getting but um um it's just a different
situation I I think you're you've made a
very very good point and I think that
the uh you know there was official
censorship during World War I there was
sort of of a of of an informal but
observed censorship during World War II
I mean the journalists who covered World
War II were in the Army I mean they wore
uniforms and travel around that way and
what that what happened was Vietnam
changed that Vietnam was reported in a
very different kind of way and it was
the first time that war reporting was
really in this Century anyway was really
uh reported as it happened oddly enough
reporting on the Civil War was probably
much better than reporting on World War
I or World War II when it comes to
really reflecting what was going on and
in the horrors of the
war it's 7 o'clock so um I think it's
witching time should we should thank the
panelist Miller time witching time it's
[Applause]
time